this is a familiar sight in somalia's
capital Mogadishu hundreds of families
are heading to the capital from areas
across the country they are fleeing a
drought that has wiped out their
livestock and left them without food and
water some of their children have died
many are malnourished
Amina Mohammed recently arrived at this
Camp She is struggling to make ends meet
when I wake up in the morning I make tea
and popcorn this will be my children's
only meal
the last two years have been hard on
people in countries like Somalia Kenya
and Ethiopia
four rainy seasons have failed it's
likely the fifth season won't make much
of a difference
across East Africa at least 36 million
people are affected including children
who are severely malnourished 11 million
Ethiopians and 4 million Kenyans are
close to starvation more than 8 million
somalis have nothing to eat millions of
farm animals have died and 16 million
people cannot get enough water we not
only affected the farming but situation
is still a critical drought also
affected the food production which means
70 percent of
food production in Somalia has been
affected by the by the drought
uh also its effect is the education
where all those young people under age
who are affected by the drought are not
going to the to the school aid agencies
say some districts are heading towards a
famine the last time one was declared in
Somalia was in 2011. our priority is
life-saving but at the same time we are
calling to focus on the recovery and
resilience that's the most important one
if we wanted to prevent it the
recurrency of the farming
hardest in Kenya living in arid areas
are relying on the government and
humanitarian organizations
Kenya has declared the drought a
national disaster
through the year Al Jazeera visited
several counties in the north to cover
the deteriorating situation people are
amazed
and cooking oil but this food
.com often and Villages that we are
talking to say it's not even enough
doctors dealing with malnutrition cases
say some children who live in remote
areas often come to the hospital when
they are already too weak to be saved
Wildlife has also been affected the
government estimates at least 200
elephants died because of the drought in
2022
the region is in the middle of another
rain season some areas have hard
rainfall but weather experts say it may
not be enough that means millions of
people who desperately need help may go
into the next year even worse off
Catherine soy Al Jazeera Nairobi